I'm jumping into the depths of the sea
to experience the wacky world of Robert
the sponge he said this is one of your
favorite episodes so here we are
spoiler I'm already annoyed first how to
roller coasters work under the water not
only its gravity massively affected by
buoyancy and water resistance but also
that's the structure may know that will
hold up to any safety regulations our
safety regulations even a thing here
what prevents someone from taking off
their fishy lap belt and just flinging
off into the ocean awesome we apparently
have balloons underwater if this means
the sea creature expelled precious air
in a pressurized environment until it
was large enough to float holy
I just realized that's probably what
extraterrestrials think about us when we
blow up a balloon also also do these
rides even take riders because the
ferris wheel looks like it's being
ridden by actual gloves I'm beginning to
think this whole show was written with
very little thought given to any
decisions other than whether to go with
the Acapulco gold or Sour Diesel another
fantastic day so you've been here before
considering the rest of this episode
revolves around you getting on the wrong
bus home this statement is patient zero
for me not feeling the least bit sorry
for your forgetful spongy ass flower
clouds wooden floor planks and bamboo
chairs eh let's hope you sealed those
properly the balloon will easily fit
inside that door I guess you think
making a joke about something being too
big to fit when it's clearly small
enough to go in without any friction
whatsoever is hilarious well it's not
just ask my college girlfriend episode
is a dictum misophonia suffers do you
think this happens everytime they board
the bus to travel home from glove world
they've been here before so needing
change for the bus shouldn't be that
much of a surprise also the lever that
was there a moment ago is now gone this
goes on for spongy time unless this is
an actual LED balloon it would not be
doing this much damage to the bus driver
but even so did he really have time to
apply bandages to his face in between
balloon beatings Sponge Bob clearly
starts this journey to the back of the
bus with his balloon facing forward but
as we watch him squeak away it has
somehow reversed order gloves for more
global action
but where's the other glove you said
gloves ooh are you just ignoring the
other three fingers that also need
gloves
holy barnacle Sponge Bob stole it for
his nose what an [ __ ]
also nose condoms in the shot we firmly
established into Spongebob Canon that
Patrick does not have the sort of ghibli
downstairs bits that shouldn't be
stepped on this reminds me of the time I
was seven and all the kid cousins were
dropped off at great-aunt Regina's for a
sleepover I went to say goodnight and
open the bedroom door she locked eyes
with me just as she slowly pulled her
fake teeth out and plopped them into a
cup she had a few teeth remaining that's
sort of sprouted out of her gums like
lonely dominoes I screamed she wept
I ran the kids laughed and we all
learned a valuable lesson about knocking
also if he's truly a sponge shouldn't he
just squish down to almost nothing I've
seen sponge dinosaurs come from tiny
pills so I know it's possible damn it
clearly his clothes had to tear to come
on so how in the hell is his underwear
still intact and now he's dressed again
I mean I'm not begging to see sponge
Roberts as fund Richard but are there
any rules in this universe and now I
realize rule 34 applies to spongebob
and that sponges are full of holes and I
guess I'm never sleeping again the late
inertia this door opened the opposite
direction earlier so does anything that
lives near a pineapple into the sea
makes sense I may just have answered my
own question
roll commercials you mind putting me
down spongebob just disintegrated this
being and I think he's now looking at
serving sponge 32 sponge life just wait
for someone come on now man just walk
into them there's a couch and a
full-length mirror it's likely the
women's restroom and I'm all for gender
equality so let's get some of that cozy
in the men's as well huh
do you have any idea the kind of water
pressure coming out of that toilet to
flush a 15,000 feet below sea level
sweet colonic Christ in hurricane heaven
that's got to hurt I understand the joke
here but if there's one place they
should truly understand gender fluidity
it's under water
this bus is traveling a really long way
considering they were dropped off here
and spongebob told Patrick the bus
while they were directly beside the
restroom here but this bus is driving to
the wall for what seems to take forever
which means Patrick was suddenly far
away NAT leads me to the conclusion that
they can teleport and should easily be
able to get out of rock bottom I'm
confused if they're under the sea can't
they swim selective gravity is selective
hang on a glove world the sign for the
boss was a green triangle not a red
semicircle are these two different bus
lines entirely this is a sin for needing
a degree in cryptography to understand
public transportation this happens for
the remainder of the episode in fact Bob
of the family sponge will miss 13 more
buses a zoom zip and speed by regularly
never do we understand where these buses
come from or why they stopped for such a
short amount of time it's a terrible
business model and completely
inefficient don't play me you knew who I
was when you click play no matter what
leaving the spot isn't the issue you've
been in that spot when the buses have
arrived this world is just apparently
full of pus hole ask drivers wait strike
that reverse it the sponges have
digestive systems I always thought it
was basically a kitchen cleaner sponge
with pants of square I guess at one
point my kitchen sponge did seem so
disgusting it looked like it all over
itself so maybe so the spongebob did
have money in his pockets for the bus
but how does a machine like this work
underwater it seems to run on
electricity and I just can't look I get
that this is spongebob and it's all
ridiculous but this is what I do blame
me all you like but you're the one who
invited the dominatrix into the hardware
store don't look surprised when I find
creative ways to use the allen wrench
[Music]
and how would this fool the bus driver
if this life-size cutout is facing us
and not the driver spongebob has no
bones and can shape-shift to become a
bus and drive back out of here man
why are these Giants even in this line
how would they even fit in the bus
[Applause]
and now I know that fish are born with
pants on which answers my why are they
wearing clothes question I guess many
have said spongebob would be impossible
to sin because it's too weird and those
people are right but also it's obviously
e-pass 7 and we all know that the rock
bottom bus depot closes at half past 111
some Sukkot downers also this clock is
clearly made from a discarded pokeball
and realizing the spongebob is part of
the Pokemon expanded universe is making
everything make so much more sense
there's no way 369 creatures we're
standing between Bob and this window I
doubt the veracity of your cartoon
physics and I call you out on them
forthwith why does the sign vanish when
the lights come out is he wearing armed
poops or has his face grown out and down
over a shirt you know I need a lesson on
Spongebob Anatomy so I can better
understand what's happening here I take
it back take it all back even under the
ocean cheap toys sucked the sinners for
that french fry plastic nonsense that
had the audacity to consider itself a
transformer bleed like seriously can't
believe run some experiments and find
out I volunteered to do all the tests
this fish has a light dangling in front
of its face but spongebob couldn't tell
what was approaching so I guess the big
reveal here is the deep sea creatures
exhale helium and what causes the
balloon to suddenly stop its ascension
to the surface of the sea and direct
itself to SpongeBob's house with
pinpoint accuracy
could it be sea
[Music]
mine
[Music]
[Music]
thank you you're welcome
try we're there think your sponge worthy
yeah this isn't your average everyday
darkness
this is black magic